quand la santé du pape est compromise on
l'emmène immédiatement à l'hôpital
on l'emmène pas à l'église on ne fait
pas venir un exorciste non on met son
sort entre les mains d'un médecin
matérialiste pourtant il est censé croit
à la guérison spirituelle et le pape ça
pour nassim nicholas taleb c'est la
preuve que le peuple lui même n'est pas
prêt à assumer les risques de sa fin ces
actes ne sont donc pas cohérent avec ses
idées mais c'est là un cas extrême de la
condition humaine
nous sommes tous animés par l'aversion
au risque
c'est très humain or nous avons en
réalité intérêt à aller contre de notre
nature à prendre davantage de risques je
suis romain voici aristote et vous êtes
sûr milieu de culture générale
[Musique]
j'ai lu récemment skins game traduit par
jouer sa peau de nassim nicholas taleb
et même si je ne suis pas d'accord avec
tout j'ai adoré cet essai provocateur
réhabilite la sagesse du risque dans
notre monde où la protection la
stabilité et la garantie sont si
valorise la thèse est d'autant plus
originale que nassim taleb est un trader
devenu philosophe
oui vous avez bien entendu un trader
devenu philosophe il a même fait fortune
dans la finance
grâce à ces idées philosophiques qui
sont centrés sur l'incertitude dans
cette vidéo je vais vous exposer quelles
sont d'après lui les cinq raisons de
prendre des risques
allez voir que la cinquième est
étonnante comme je le fais
systématiquement depuis les quelques
vidéos précédentes je vous permet de
télécharger mes notes de lecture en
cliquant soit sur le lien qui s'affiche
en haut à droite soit sur celui qui est
dans la description puis en me laissant
votre adresse email petite précision ne
soyez pas étonnés si les citations que
vous trouvez dans ses notes de lecture
dans cette vidéo où dans l'article de
blogs ne sont pas dans le livre ou dans
les résumés qu'on trouve sur internet
c'est juste qu'au moment de commander le
livre kindle
on monte un peu pince comme la version
anglaise était moins cher je me suis dit
oh ça ira
et en fait ça a été assez difficile à
traduire
parce que nassim taleb un style très
particulier et qui créent même des
expressions et des concepts donc avec le
recul j'ai fait une bêtise
et puis je vous dis surtout ça pour que
vous sachiez que les extraits que j'ai
retenues ne sont pas issus de la version
française mais de ma galère de
traducteurs ce que vous pouvez faire
pour me consoler de tout ce temps perdu
ces données un pouce vu la vidéo et puis
vous abonner à la chaîne si vous aimez
la vulgarisation de la panse
après ces précisions on peut commencer
la première raison de prendre des
risques sel
e quand je marchais avec aristote le
long de la mer au début il restait
souvent près de l'eau puis un jour de
tempête il a reçu une grosse vague et il
fait 3 kg 1
à tel point que j'ai craint qu'il soit
emporté depuis vous voyez venir
il reste relativement loin de l'eau et
il est très méfiant lorsque la mer est
agitée
nassim taleb site le proverbe grec pâte
et matam athema tard que j'ai traduit
par ce qui a été souffert a été appris
en clair on apprend par soi-même en
prenons le risque de recourir à une
certaine manière de faire on en subit
les conséquences puis on a juste le tire
parfois radicalement comme aristote un
qui a été traumatisée par une vague
d'après nassim taleb ce phénomène
fondamental devrait nous inviter à nous
méfier des expériences en tous genres
fitness lifestyle sommeil respiration
sauf s'ils prennent un risque en faisant
dépendre leur rétribution de la
performance de la personne qui conseille
mais fondamentalement l'efficacité de
leur enseignement dépend de la pratique
parce qu'il faut toujours prendre le
risque d'échouer de stagner voire d'être
ridicule pour progresser réapprendre la
sagesse populaire connaît bien ce
phénomène
on apprend de ses erreurs moi par
exemple comme j'ai suffisamment souffert
à traduire ce livre je ne préférerais
plus la version anglaise pour économiser
5 heures
[Musique]
d'après nassim taleb si votre chirurgien
ressemble à celui ci vous devez vous
méfier en revanche si vous pouvez le
confondre avec un boucher l'a en fait
c'est bon signe
pourquoi donc faudrait-il choisir celui
qui vous fait peur parce que s'il prend
le risque d'effrayer ses patients c'est
qui compense largement la défiance qui
vous inspirent par un surcroît de
compétences tandis qu'avec le chirurgien
en mode george clooney c'est le surcroît
de confiance que vous inspire son
apparence qui compense un possible
défaut de compétence ou même une
négligence une moindre qualité de
service due à la confiance excessive
vous placé en lui il y aurait donc plus
généralement second nassim taleb un
arbitrage pour parler comme les
économistes entre la compétence et
l'apparence une apparence excessivement
soigner est conforme à la fonction
indiquerait probablement un défaut de
compétence
al'inverse le professionnel très
compétent peut lui prendre le risque de
négliger son apparence le contact avec
la réalité filtre l'incompétence écrite
à l'aide parce que la réalité est
aveugle aux apparences
je ne suis pas du tout d'accord en
revanche quand il transpose cet
arbitrage à la parole écrite qu'orale il
affirme que les personnes qu'on comprend
le plus facilement sont des menteurs or
à mon modeste avis il confond peut-être
la clarté du discours avec l'effet du
discours
je suis d'accord pour dire qu'un
discours éblouissant peut-être
fallacieux en revanche un discours clair
les probablement beaucoup moins parce
qu'il est très facile de par sa clarté
d'évaluer sa pertinence et puis dans ma
modeste expérience ce sont surtout la
complexité et le jargon qui servent à
dissimuler une déficience de fonds mais
bon c'est un détail ce que vous devez
retenir c'est que si votre chirurgien
une nuit il va faire les choses bien
[Musique]
a new york les acteurs de broadway
aiment à se retrouver chez lindy un
traiteur pour discuter des pièces et ils
ont remarqué un truc c'est qu'un show
programmé pour cent jours dure
généralement son jour de plus ce que ça
veut dire au niveau théorique c'est que
la durée de vie restante de certaines
choses serait dur et à leur durée de vie
passé si on revient à l'exemple du show
de broadway
il ya de bonnes chances de durer 100
jours de plus roots un jour parce que le
fait qu'il n'ait pas déjà été
déprogrammé prouve qu'il plaît au public
et donc qu'il trouvera probablement
encore des spectateurs supplémentaires
si on généralise plus les choses non
périssables et en particulier les idées
les hypothèses scientifiques plus ces
choses dures c'est à dire plus elle
survivre longtemps plus elles sont
robustes à la critique et à la
réputation donc plus elles ont de
chances d'être vrai c'est l'effet lindy
du nom du traiteur prisé par les acteurs
de broadway pour découvrir la vérité il
faut donc soumettre l'hypothèse au
risque de la critique et de la
réfutation alors le temps fera son
oeuvre et par le darwinisme du monde
intellectuel
seules les idées pertinentes survivent
le problème selon nassim taleb c'est
qu'il existe des gens qui ont intérêt à
entraver cette émergence darwinienne de
la vérité l'universitaire pour lequel
seul compte l'avis de ses pairs le
journaliste qui écrit surtout pour les
journalistes ou encore thomas piketty
dont l'autorité intellectuelle
reposerait sur la connivence des mandats
mais je m'arrête là parce que je vais
vous proposer un petit best-of des
attaques de nassim taleb
en conclusion de la vidéo
[Musique]
alors vous vous souvenez avant d'être
traumatisé par une vague
aristote se balader près de l'eau mais
pourquoi n'at-il jamais sauté dans la
mer il aurait pu parce qu'elle n'est
généralement pas très agitée et bien
c'est simplement que son instinct une
forme de connaissance hérités de
génération immémorial de chihuahua
son instinct lui dit que c'est dangereux
de plonger dans la mer parmi les
chihuahuas qui ont pris le risque un
jour une partie probablement la majorité
vu leur taille n'ont pas survécu
et ceux qui sont sortis vivants de la
première baignade ont ensuite survécu
parce qu'ils en ont tiré l'expérience du
danger j'ai évoqué pour la troisième a
raison de prendre des risques
le darwinisme du savoir mais le risque
joue bien sûr aussi un rôle dans le
derby nice mme du monde matériel
c'est le risque qui filtre les
comportements et c'est parce favorables
à la survie et ceux qui ne le sont pas
tous ne survient pas pour une raison
écrit taleb
mais tout ce qui survit survie pour une
raison par exemple il a fallu que
beaucoup d'avions ce crash avant que les
vols ne soient aussi sûr qu'aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai à l'échelle collective
et sur nine génération mais aussi à
l'échelle de l'être vivant et dans un
laps de temps court parce que l'être
vivant adapte son comportement en
fonction de son expérience du risque par
exemple
aristote s'est brûlé une seule fois en
tentant de voler de la nourriture dans
une poêle chaude et aujourd'hui il se
méfie de ce récipient chez les humains
la nécessité du risque pour la survie
explique par exemple la dangerosité de
l'administrateur qui est généralement
protéger du risque
il se contente de le transférer ce qui
empêche l'émergence des meilleures
solutions vous ne convaincrez jamais
quelqu'un qu'il a tort écrit taleb cela
la réalité le peut
ainsi d'un côté le risque sélectionne
les idées et les comportements
favorables à la survie et de l'autre la
déconnexion du risque pérennise
l'inefficacité l'inefficience et le
danger mais aussi la laideur morale
[Musique]
vous savez ce que fera nassim taleb si
vous lui voler sa place de parking
il va sortir son téléphone et vous
filmez a priori ça doit vous faire
réfléchir ça devrait révéler que vous
n'assumez pas réellement le risque lié à
votre action
cet exemple montre que le risque a une
portée morale
nassim taleb développe notamment deux
dimensions
la première c'est le risque de la
publicité de l'acte comme avec la vidéo
du vol de la place de parking
parce que la publicité de l'acte révèle
si on l'assument ou non de ce point de
vue il faut reconnaître le courage des
personnes qui expriment publiquement des
opinions controversées
un peu comme nassim taleb qui n'y va pas
avec le dos de la cuillère la seconde
dimension de la portée morale du risque
c'est la cohérence des idées des paroles
et des actes
vous vous souvenez de mon accroche le
pape qui prêchent la force de l'esprit
ne se soignent pourtant pas par la
prière et il ya plein d'autres exemples
les millionnaires anticapitaliste ou les
rentiers qui prêchent la prise de risque
les écologistes extrémistes qui ne
vivent pas dans la forêt les
restaurateurs qui ne consomment pas
leurs propres produits
les conseillers en tous genres qui
n'appliquent pas leurs propres conseils
encore une fois
nassim taleb a ses têtes de turc mais
c'est l'être humain en général qui a
tendance à plus parler qu'il n'agit et à
ne pas traduire en actes ses convictions
et ses parents or d'aller bekri si votre
vie privée contredit vos opinions
intellectuelle cela annule vos idées les
intellectuels pas votre vie privée
si vos actions privées ne sont pas
généralisables alors vous ne pouvez pas
avoir d'idées générales du coup on peut
en déduire trois règles pour mener une
vie honorable
elles ne sont pas donner explicitement
dans le livre c'est moi qui synthétise
première règle agir avant de parler et
préférer l'action à la parole pour se
confronter au monde réel
deuxième règle ne théorise etc avec
prudence et humilité
enfin troisième règle vivre les
conséquences de saisie l'action est
supérieur à la parole parce que c'est
elle qui contraint l'homme à assumer le
risque inhérent à la réalité facta nonne
verbe je peux résumer la vidéo avec une
toute petite phrase le risque est un
filtre
ils filtrent l'erreur le danger
l'incompétence et même la malhonnêteté
plus fondamentalement vivre c'est
connaître le risque alors autant
l'embrasser allez je passe au best of
des attaques de nassim taleb
mais tout d'abord je veux bien un pouce
bleus aussi la vidéo vous a plu bien sûr
et puis
abonnez-vous à la chaîne si vous aimez
la vulgarisation de la pensée alors pour
nassim taleb roberte rubine l'ancien
patron de la banque citigroup qui s'est
considérablement enrichi en ayant mené
au bord de la faillite est l'incarnation
même de l'aléa moral c'est-à-dire le
fait de ne pas assumer les conséquences
des risques couvre les administrateurs
sont dans le privé comme dans le public
un fléau les expatriés des
multinationales sont des esclaves
au diable le salarié est un chien
domestique comparé à l'entrepreneur qui
est un loup sauvage mais l'entrepreneur
qui prend des risques avec l'argent
d'investisseurs est un lâche
les élites modernes sont constitués
d'intellectuels idiot thomas piketty et
les intellectuels académiques sont des
donneurs de leçons qui vivent dans leur
microcosme
les chercheurs se prostituent l'économie
est une fausse science l'éducation
supérieure américaine est un racket les
philanthropes sont juste des vanités les
experts de la géopolitique sont de faux
savants et lui une nassim taleb
un preneur de risque merci d'avoir
regardé la vidéo jusqu'au bout j'espère
vraiment qu'elle vous a plu pour ma part
j'ai pris plaisir mise à part l'effort
de traduction à lire jouer sa paume de
nassim taleb
alors vous pouvez m'aider et
m'encourager à prendre le risque de
faire de nouvelles vidéos et aussi de
tenter de nouvelles choses de trois
manières qui sont compatibles
premièrement en donnant un coup double à
la vidéo deuxièmement on vous abonnant à
la chaîne si vous aimez la vulgarisation
de la pensée et troisièmement en
laissant un petit commentaire
je vous permet également de télécharger
mes notes de lecture comme je le fais
systématiquement depuis les quelques
vidéos précédentes
si vous voulez ma synthèse et crise
détaillé du livre et sur le blog ou si
vous voulez lire directement le livre
tous les liens sont dans la description
je suis romain je suis avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous étiez sur milliers
d'êtres culture générale
prenez le risque de vous intéresser au
meilleur de la pensée mais sans prendre
la tête
[Musique]